We have to digitize Keanu's essence
Action!
I think we could do all of Keanu Reeves in a day.
If Keanu's not right, the video doesn't work.
Yeah, Keanu Reeves
[weird noises]
I'm such a big fan of Keanu Reeves man.
Like I've loved him since speed. That was an awesome movie
Of course the matrix, I mean
"He's the one"
There's all these articles about how nice Keanu Reeves is.
Keanu gives all of his money away
Keanu takes the time to hang out with homeless people
I think the world needs more people like Keanu Reeves.
You guys remember the Tom Cruise video, right?
We had a Tom Cruise impersonator to come in, do his thing and we put a Tom Cruise deep fake over his face
right
The result was jaw-dropping.
Nikko learned about the technology in the Tom Cruise video, and I thought well
How funny would it be if Keanu Reeves stopped the armed robbery with kindness?
So look if I can't work with Keanu right now, I think this is the next best thing
We have to digitize Keanu's essence.
So we got to run a test
We got to see if we can put Keanu Reeves face on my body. Just see if it works
So we're doing this Keanu Reeves thing and since I'm done let's do a real test
I got a wig, I put a suit on,  just so I did here's the goofiest looking thing
Sorry, Keanu Reeves?
H-hi, how you doin'
Wow, man!
That wig, man!
It's very strange it looks a little better than I thought it would like it was so few iterations to you know,
He like definitely like he bends his hands like all the way back. Full palm, you know
And he's constantly trying to open those pickle jars
It's like you tell me to smile scan or if you feel like suppressants
yeah, the wig makes it look like off his meds or something like that
Got a loop being lost
I can't wait to make this video
You may have seen our Tom Cruise deep fake video, which we titled the best deep picture on the Internet. It look great
But if you look closely you could tell is the deep pit
It wasn't perfect, but we learned a lot
And now for this Keanu Reeves video it's time to put that training to use and make this one perfect
So here's what we're gonna do.
Lesson 1 Keanu Reeves has long black hair so we get to frame the entire face
It's just black but Keanu Reeves has a widow peak and it's hard to find wigs that have widow Peaks that look good
So we're wearing a baseball cap. those two things alone frame the face very nicely.
lesson two
We're going to light this seam. Anyway, that gives us flat underneath lighting
So we're not getting a lot of shadow on the face or not getting really direct solid lighting
We're not getting crisp shadows that has to be recreated. The bill of the Hat casts a shadow on the face
There's gonna get some nice even under lighting
lesson 3: profile shots
Tthe deep fake can kind of do profile shots
But the problem is if somebody else's nose is bigger than say your actor's nose. It can be putting on to the face
Well, you just have another big nose sticking out below their nose, and that's a problem
So we need to plan the scene in such a way to never have the issue really looking sideways
Lesson 4
deep fakes are really only 128 by 128 pixels in the screen here of 1080p
That's where is only this big. The problem is you can't film any close-up
So what we're doing right now, you can't do that with the deep fake so it would look really blurry
But we don't worry about that
If we film it on the cellphone, we're gonna film the whole thing
Like it's found footage on a cell phone and we're gonna film it vertical
So that's gonna let us keep the face tinier in the frame
So the last thing we're gonna do is we're going to teach Rai a much better face compared to the Tom Cruise one
I think I trained the Tom Cruise face for like a hundred thousand iterations meaning that it's running a calculation over and over and over
And over and over again it did that a hundred thousand times. I thought that was great
I thought that was enough.
Turns out I was wrong
we're going to giving it a really good Keanu Reeves data set with a lot of different examples of his face from a lot of
Different angles and I've been training this Keanu Reeves deep fake model for like ten days straight
Boy, this is satisfying seeing those faces just crisp up nicely
We had a great response to the "Boston Dynamics" video
it came out and we wonder this thing with this one. We need to strike while the iron's hot
It's important. This video comes out in a timely manner because we wait too long
All that hard work goes to waste. The problem is we kind of like are perfectionists here, especially Clint
So I need to sit down with the team. We got to talk about this
We've gotta make sure it's going to look as good as it can look but that it's also going to come out when it needs
To come out. There's a ticking time bomb on this video. E3 was when all the keanu love came back
And right now it's the end of June we just released the deep fake video about a week ago
If want to follow suit with the success we've had over the last two months
Basically, we have two to three weeks to release the video
If you're telling me that Wednesday is the day then that's what it is
If you wait any longer
There's no point in even making the video and I think it's a great video and you should make it
I know that by Wednesday
We can make it happen and we'll be doing the best what we got we've done more with less in the past
We know it can be a success. The clock is ticking. All right, Wednesday it is
Is that meeting about you filmed this video or we don't film it?
We don't have an actor, but we need someone who can impersonate Keanu Reeves
I still think there's something to be said about
Getting a look like actor and then dubbing it after with someone who can do the voice
Plan C
Jake
I told you about my shallow fakes. So these deep fakes are pretty sweet. Right but something that I've been doing it's called shallow fakes
whoa
Now I might look like Keanu Reeves, right?
You might be buying it, but I'm taking it to the next level but using this piece of tape right here
Okay
Keanu Reeves is one of the nicest guys known to the world and we've got these wonderful
Wonderful patrons out there and that made me want to go out and do something nice for everyone in the studio
Let me show you what I mean
Hey Nick, hey, I just wanted to do something nice for you because our patrons do such nice things. We're
over have you heard Astro DG or are we Abu Bakr have you heard of Philip Oxford or
Helen Almanza war master 2 3 6 if you tell you have to do all of this told me to do all this
Ok, I also Matt. He said to clean your keyboard for you
Actually Thank You Keanu hey, are you Peter France? It's really not it, huh?
It's great to meet you Oh, have you heard of will Robertson our patrons? Yeah, we ready Adolf Oh
Have you heard of not a Canadian spy my favorite person on the planet?
Actually, it looks like your phone could use a little bit here. Yeah. Hey Ren. Have you heard a radio Guerrero? Jr
Or Mitch plan ski they do something nice for everyone in the studio. Yeah, let me do something nice for you
That's real it's it's beyond what is this, you know, have you heard of glitch cube
Use Bailey that's got some smudges on it
Looks like Christians not here, but I'm gonna tell him about Brian and Togiak and Raymond - bought because they're also two great patrons
Ok, what's this ok?
So so if you guys are interested in supporting everything that they do in this studio consider patreon
It supports all of these videos me nice guy Keanu Reeves. I just I gotta go. I gotta go got some things to do. I
Was at my wit's end we scoured the Internet we scoured the internet for anyone who looked like Keanu Reeves
I was like it has to be right if Kennedy was not right video doesn't work and I fail Keanu Reeves
I was scrolling through Facebook and I found the only person who I know of that can pull this off
they just called me up and said hey, I want you to be counter Reeves and I said
Okay, I can try that. Everybody's a voice actor. He's a stuntman he is
511 we'll see if it works
These habanero crackling sound we got Keanu Reeves here today
Anyone that Keanu interacts with it's gonna change their soul, it's like Jesus
Generally speaking. The only rules you have to really follow is avoid doing profile
We also want to avoid obstructions in front of States
But as long as you can see the camera and I can see your eyebrows from the camera. It's fine
Now in 20 minutes I still have this stunt hopefully Clinton can do this the flip guys let's rehearse
If any shots going to like be a hard one this is it
I'm a little worried about this because that bent over and he's gonna be doing a lot of moving like she's got a lot of
Hair we're gonna in his face and I just I might be a bit of an issue. What's the EDFA?
No, Pratt doesn't hurt himself 3 2 1 actually
It was less than an hour to finish the day
So, it's Monday week after the shoot and we're finally looking at the final edit here I think it feels pretty good
Oh my god, Keanu Reeves
I
Thought the Edit was pretty solid from the deep fake territory here
That's a little challenging that hair in front of space
I'm a little worried about so see if there's maybe one other take where the hair is not hanging
I'm not saying we need to change it right now. I'm just saying be aware. This one might become an issue as well
Lawrence was really solid. We were thinking we're gonna have to do ADR, which is your voice replacement for the actor down the line
But he sounds a lot like eonni once said there's no way we compute
Effectively you have guns pointed at each other's hands
I mean Ruben, here's a voice actor in the voice for Ken's in a smash brothers ultimate bring it on
Got some chops. So the next step here is plenties to lock the edit
He needs to export all the clips that are going to have the deep baked some of it
You need to take those image sequences. We need to extract the faces from all them
We need to check the alignment on the faces making sure that the eyes are exactly on the eyes and mouth
That's exactly on the mouth. Otherwise, the face will jump around train the algorithm Allen the final images and then export Alton
Over here, I've no mustache. Do you guys know this one? So you might not but whatever. He'll take a look
We don't hurt Brett so we have to do this as an effect
Unfortunately because it's nice to do things practical when Brett's involved. We got to keep him safe
We've already heard him in a previous video didn't want to do that again. We have the background plate right here
There's still a bunch of pieces of his head that are there, you know, that would be in the background behind the spinning heads
We got to take those out remove Brett's head from the shot
And then we added in the shot of Brett doing a little spinny spoon
If you want to take this clip and animate it into a music video of sorts and then upload it
Please tweet it at me. And so basically what I did was I I saluted his head and stabilized the footage to his head
So we can take that we can
Superimpose it on to the shot to merge these two shots together as a fine frames where the faces in each shot lined up
roughly and we have normal Brett face right here and then
We're good to go
Pretty simple effect actually, but very effective an effective effect. All right, Nico
I have the final cut of the counter video. I can export some final frames for you
Will you be able to do some stuff overnight? Ah?
It's been a long day clamp I mean the thing is I could keep baking it
but honestly at this point
I'm like two hundred and thirty thousand iterations into this fake and it looks about as good as it's gonna get
I think this should be a concern of mine considering all the other cost of the studio
But it cost 50 cents for every hour that I'm running this GPU. Really? Yeah
I've been running deep fake crunches around the clock for two weeks now three weeks right three times seven times
24 times 0.5 you spent
$250 of deep fakes Wow if we're not doing any key on your baking tonight
Then that gives us literally two days to do all of it. You think it's possible to fix a scorpion game tomorrow also
I think we could do all of Keanu Reeves in a day
My new computer
Pocket Puget systems Thank You, Nick. Give a knife. Oh my god
I can find the that's rendered four times faster. Now, it's gonna help me do this key on a deep fake a lot faster
It's gonna help us make this deadline
My octane renders are gonna go so fast
Let's take a look at what's in this thing video cards RTX cards atti
It smells like a new car in here
Holy crap
I can I can bake some deep fakes and render out of cinema 4d and octane at the same exact time
You guys watching this video right now who know anything about computers? You're probably screaming. I plugged my harddrive into the motherboard, right? I
Got my this league mistress thing right now because literally today's third like midway through Thursday, I only have Friday to finish this video
So I am hoping I can get all of these deep fakes done by the end of the day program called face swap
Nico turned me on to this program. Give me a little tutorial how to use it and how to harness its power
It's true power. I'm cranking through
we got 13 shots of
Rubin to deep bay Keanu Reeves on to the shots get longer and longer as the video goes on once it's out of phase
Whap it has to be composited in After Effects. So we're really kind of crunched for time here
I'm eager to get working on the face flop stuff myself a big list of things to
To do which is just how things go here sometimes
Face whopping yet. I'll get there
I'm using my computer in Nico's computer to
Make this deadline while I'm actually training up my computer and then I'm setting up all the other shots on Nico's computer
Thank goodness to puget is saving me some time
Two thousand iterations is just what I need
What suppose that's basically like it's getting more crystal-clear the more iterations you have in two thousand iterations for like a wide medium shot
That's gonna be just right, but for the close-up shot 13, David
I need like 15 thousand iterations doesn't take a couple hours Daniel. Luckily. Niko's P trains model to the moon and back so
We're in safe hands
Huge dude, I don't why I'm being weird. Yes. We're on the home stretch right now. Today's Friday video goes up tomorrow
I'd say we're like a little over halfway me Peter and Nico are comping
Everything together sim is mixing together sound and we're all on it. We're all having a good time. Isn't that right Peter?
For puzzling it faces. It's pretty easy people. But this really cool idea actually and Peter had nothing to do with it
All we have to do is add grain and compression because it's iPhone footage. It's garbage
So we got to make him look like garbage even though he's in a very handsome man, Nico. I just wanna rap out 13
So shot 13 is 32 seconds long we had to do manual face alignments for the first time and it's looking pretty good
Try 13. I
Think that's pretty good. It's really weird. It's like I'm generating a new face. That's not our original actor
It's not quite key on you. It's like in-between, but it's better than nothing. It's better than really blurry and obviously fake
I'm just super impressed by these programs
5 and 6 are done
We were being daring mirrors said we were gonna have all the effects on like one or two days turns out it's happening
Here 7 we're like 85%
So yeah, once you guys are done with that and your computer's a free effort an hour-long render
Then we'll knock it out. I think we're gonna be able to get a beer and a Smash Bros duel
and I think it's gonna be one of those fridays so
Dean watch this
That leaves one more shot. Nico's working on it now
Waiting on me now, it's the last thing it's going out right now. It's ready put it in
Every all the files are in tier 3 everything's finished
You can't be dead now get up
Now we're going to work
All right here is stuff together
Is anyone that Keanu interacts with
It's gonna change their soul. It's like Jesus
Get ready to see a million copycats of this
I'm also kind of worried that like Keanu is not gonna be chill with this and we'll see you see how this goes
Yeah, no, don't hurt me, please Gianni. Oh if you're watching I hope you enjoyed the video
Rendering the switch is coming out
Beers here switches in hand guys
Dean we're missing you, dude
I'll give a shout to the face flop devs. They've been helping me learn a lot about deep fakes and algorithms
You guys can find faceswap on the programs to use on github. Thank you so much